hey my name is Andrew couch and I'm the
creator of sweet board a dashboard for
conducting sentiment analysis and text
mining for Twitter data you may have
seen my sweet board on shiny apps I Oh
however you can also download it from my
github where it's github.com slash
Andrew - couch slash sweet board for
this demonstration I'll be using sweet
board with token which allows you to not
have to manually enter in my Twitter API
stuff right here so when you download
sweet board you can just select
everything and run it as run the our
script and then our studio will pop out
the app so what's great about sweet
board is it's a pretty high-level tool
for any analyst to just conduct basic
text mining on it's made for Twitter
data and you really don't need any
programming experience to use it so for
here you can type in a user to scrape
their tweets and you can specify it the
amount of tweets the reason why it's
3,200 is the cap is Twitter API API only
allows you to scrape 3,200 tweets when
you scrape those tweets you can also
download it as a CSV or you can use it
for future use
and here is where you can upload a file
of tweets to analyze for the first week
board so right now I'll just open it up
you know upload some tweets that I
already scraped these are Donald Trump
tweets I scraped about 2059 tweets when
you upload it or scrape the tweets
they'll give you some KPIs of basic
summary statistics of the metrics and
also show you the most recent tweets
that you scrape from it I'm gonna break
this demonstration into different videos
one for each tab because of my video
recording constraints however we'll
start with an Grandma analysis and
Engram analysis is just analyzing
groupings of words so engrams is just
the end gram so right now we're at 2
which is 2
grams which is also commonly referred to
as by grams as you can see of the is the
most common however we can also change
it to try grams such as three words
roofings or we can do quad rams which
there are four word groupings or we can
just do the traditional bag of words
which is just a unigram or just a single
word you may have noticed that these
words are kind of useless because it
just contains like the two of and it
doesn't really adding any meaning we can
use remove stop words which will remove
comma and filler words and I'll show you
some more some more valuable information
such as our country's present Trump
stuff like that and what's cool is it
applies to any kind of Engram so you can
do it to a trigram or you can do it to a
the basic bag of word additionally some
people will find that they only need to
filter out one word it's right here I
might want to filter out just the so
type info and I'll filter out any word
any Engram mccain's where the kidding
that contains the word also you may want
to find anagrams that contain asbestos
if ik word so what Donald Trump I know
Donald Trump does not like to know
Democrats so I'm gonna look up and grams
that continual word Democrats so here he
says do-nothing Democrats he says
something about Democrats he wrapped he
does a lot of references it at two
Democrats additionally you may notice
the bottom chart which is a negation
Engram and what this finds is the first
word it'll find and grams like you today
in whatever word it is so right now it's
the negation word so any trigram that
the first word contains not right so not
have been not even close and it's a
common thing to analyze word
associations with negations so another
negation word would be no so we'll see
that so no quid pro quo no collusion no
really [ __ ] stuff like that however it
is really just finding Engram that
contains for the first engrams
you could say um Joe right it'll
probably go something Joe Biden Joe
something as you can see with trigrams
it's a little messy as there's a ton of
ties however we can switch it to to
amazing Joe Biden stuff like that so it
works the negations however it's really
finding the first word that contains
this value that's it for this tab all
pause this page and we'll go on to the
next tab okay so we just figured
finished and grandma analysis tab and
you can just do basic analysis on Ngram
or word groupings and also find word
associations so now on to the sentiment
analysis so with the sentiment analysis
tab or you're first gonna see the Bing
lexicon right here it's showing the top
five positive and negative words however
you can also switch it to AFI n into
[ __ ] to offerin and you can switch it to
my favorite NRC so they're basically
different types of sentiment they both
have their pros and cons and you can
just analyze whatever you want so right
here we may notice that for negative
words with the panga lexicon always
makes sense however for the positive
words Trump does not make a lot of sense
because Donald Trump will say his name
on it and Trump is considered a positive
word so we can also filter the sentiment
analysis right here so it removes Trump
from the sentiment analysis so now we
have more representative sample of the
most positive words lastly is right here
we can find that this is a bigram
analysis or an Graham analysis where
I'll find the top and engrams for
positive and negative sentiment right
here these are thank you
so maybe the ink is a commonly
associated positive word and with Engram
analysis we can see that he says thank
you a lot you can also switch it to just
a basic you know Graham or bad words
which is the same thing as this but in a
different format however you can also go
to try Graham
stuff like that so it's pretty cool just
to see a different display of
information with the same data
additionally you can look at positive
negative trends for tweets per day right
here you can see positive and negative
sentiment has gone up additionally his
tweets per day have gone up so you might
have to account for that and right here
is the top five positive negative tweets
right here so he's saying some very
negative stuff right here and he's
saying some pretty positive stuff with
some congratulations and that's really
it for the sentiment analysis you don't
need to remove stop words because it
uses a little excellent dictionary and
you can do some basic filtering like the
Engram analysis from the previous tab
I'm going to pause this video and we'll
move on to tweet metrics so we finished
up sentiment analysis and we'll move on
to tweet metrics so with tweet metrics
we can just analyze basic tweet KPIs
such as daily favorites daily retweets
just daily tweets as you can see you can
do maybe an outlier analysis we're right
here we've got a lot of tweets I wonder
why you might have to investigate that
right here it's a this is a top and
tweets common words so it finds rankings
of KPIs so the top 100 tweets of top one
so the top 100 favorites for the tweets
will be right here top 100 retweet
tweets will be right here and we can
also find the words of associations with
it so given the top 100 favorited tweets
make America great as was mentioned the
most out of them the United States was
mentioned in for the top retweets we can
change it to just a basic bag of words
the two and not really great information
we can switch it to diagrams our country
the United States so he mentions a lot
about the United States you also change
it to top 250 words if you want on a
better sample and we can change it to
top three
Thapa to trigrams to make them more to
analyze something else so you know I was
top 250 favorite tweets the Republican
Party's mentioned a lot and right here
you can see just top 5 favorite tweets
right additionally we have some
additional we can use the remove stop
words however it's not as useful for
this right now
however maybe we might find diagrams to
be a little bit more useful so Joe Biden
still it's pretty tied so I wouldn't put
any merit to this analysis right now
however maybe a general bag of words
will brief mention again not the
greatest so we can only gain too many
insights from this right now however
maybe there's something here
but I'm not really sure at this moment
ok ok
right here top end this is on just basic
mentions so it's finding the top 5 most
mentioned people given those tweets so
Fox News to mention the most followed by
Fox and Friends CNN Lou Dobbs and Sean
Hannity we can change it to the top like
7 Tucker Carlson White House man we can
go even farther however we're gonna come
with visual constraints where I'll start
getting smushed so we'll just put it
back to 5 right here is a great way to
analyze tweet metric distributions so
this is basically kind of like a bee
testing or you want to find tweets that
contain a word and tweets that don't
contain the word and see how they
perform differently so right here let's
analyze just Democrats right here I'll
just do a basic analysis so right here
it finds all tweets that contain the
word Democrats and compares to all
tweets that don't have Democrats in it
maybe we can see how in it the black
line is the median for each thing so
right now Democrats maybe perform a
little bit less but they're still very
similar
same with retweets in fact right here
if we look at it since the scales are a
little bit different
right here right here that Democrats
will receive more retweets in the
average tweet that doesn't contain
Democrats so you can gain some pretty
good insights with just how to tweet how
word associations work with a tweet and
their general kpi's lastly this is a
another AV testing where it's containing
the top 50% of tweets with the bottom
50% of tweets and it's finding and it's
finding chord associations right now
it's fine what it's saying is given the
top 50% of tweets and the bottom 50%
tweets the words that distinguish those
groupings for the for the high
performers or Baltimore Alijah
Elle Cummings and passo the bottom 50
performing tweets could turn these
contain these words and obviously you
can you can change them metrics on what
is considered a bottom performing tweet
so for me 50% doesn't make that one
sense however 20% makes more sense so
the bottom 20% performing favorited
tweets here's what here's some word
associations so bottom performer tweets
have the word Facebook and Wisconsin it
additionally you can change the metrics
to retweets so to top 8% retweets
compared to the bottom 20% retweets we
can see what has the most what is the
largest word associations so
high-performing or the remaining 80%
contained shift the bottom 20 contain
interviewed and additionally you can
change the engrams tube diagrams and
additionally it's really not great to
compare as the top 80% as being
high-performing it would really be
easier just to change it to 80% so right
here the top one the top 20% tweets
contain a app things they they hate
stuff like that the bottom 80% just
contain these things these are very
normal tweets however high-performing
are these tweets
and from me just understanding the
tweets a app is actually a step so it's
tweets that contain ASAP Rocky
when ASAP Rocky was being released you
can also change it a step so ASA when
you create ASAP that must mean a huge
tweet for him to tweet and you got a lot
of he got a lot of favorites from it but
additionally what's a look at just
bottom point percent so bottom 20%
tweets he's talked about a book link and
stuff like that and you also you can
change it to trigrams and I'm pretty
sure I mentioned this already but the
way it's doing it is it's using tf-idf
which is a Engram or word weighting
system where it contains bit where it's
trying to find commonly used words in a
group that are also rare among the
entire data so right here it says for
the bottom 20% tweets a common word that
was used it was great book was basically
create in book however in the 8
remaining 80% tweets these words were
very common and were you that could also
identify this grouping of 80 percent
tweets okay so we finished the basic
tweet metrics and that's basically the
entire dashboard this dashboard as Roy
just made for basic Twitter and tweet
analytics you can do a lot with just
basic Engram analysis and doing a/b
testing and comparing groupings of
tweets by I'm dividing them instead of
making subdivisions I think it's really
a great tool because you really don't
need a high of a lot of technical skills
to actually use this dashboard you
really need a lot of domain knowledge as
for applications I think this really
could help marketing firms who just
start a marketing campaign such as a
social media campaign on Twitter you can
find I also coupon associations so say
Chipotle release coupons on their tweets
they could understand how I perform
compared to themselves
additionally financial analysts could
use this to scrape financial data or
analyze market sentiment
finally I am gonna be adding a some more
features and some more tabs specifically
like a random sampling feature that
would sample random tweets and you could
stream in tweet so you can just analyze
just basic sentiment through that I hope
you learned a little more about sweeper
and I also hope that you can use it and
conduct some great analysis